[Music]
so welcome to this class and I look at
your games and shake my head and then
you hear all the noise inside this is a
ladder game that was played today solid
ok and both players are approximately
eighteen hundred plus or minus tax they
still play better than the Cardinals
giving up six runs in one inning
horrible ok e4x clam best buy test which
lunatic said that you cracked very good
okay then Bradley played g6 question
mark ok giving away the center solid ok
good Bishop g7 how come this doesn't
work I can use this that's why how come
you how come in this chess space I can't
click two square well they haven't set
like as bad as possible ok Bishop g7
Knight f3 X clam oh well that's a I move
to not I move three Bishop III c5 so if
you take it this should be too
complicated more complicated for Wyatt
9c3 now we're gonna transpose to a
dragon except white play the illegal
move Bishop takes e4 or your score
keeping is not up to snuff one of them
Bishop takes d4 X clam Knight takes
looks like it transposed to a dragon
so then comer would be happy ok Bishop
takes d4 that's legal Knight f6 Queen d2
knight c6 and blacks play a little
better now because the bishop side d4
normal you don't want to lose your
bishop because then you don't have it
right right that time if you're taking
notes because bishops are good now white
didn't want to move his bishop and save
it because that would make sense so he
tried to give his other bishop away
there should be five it castles it now
white didn't know which bishop to give
away so he actually saved his bishop now
the dish about b5 is well placed
this should be three and now you played
a good move you all right over there
good yeah good job
yeah nice g4x clam and the Sicilian you
want to play Knight g4 if they let you
and in this city they let you so you get
to might cover knows I'm talking about
like Knight g4 and then resigns my
covers like Queen F to mate half the
games I play okay so he saved his bishop
and then queen f two mates coming Queen
b6 now I could be wrong but his wife
threatening Bishop takes Knight and
queens eggs Bishop I mean black yeah
okay so why play the interesting move a
Forex clam so after a six with the game
have ended I guess right a six and we I
would have stopped looking at the game
we've got another one well maybe a five
no I just take Queen takes B - yeah and
that's what happened okay but I was
wrong as usual Knight d5 X clam although
yeah like White's position terrible but
that is X clam I'll give him that
Queen da saving his Queen takes takes
Knight b4 in the opening if you play
Knight before you did something wrong
there's no opening you play Knight
before Christ fans I don't think you
ever play Knight all you doing oh wait
is that night b4 know what about in the
game cuz spar of shear off where he
played the exchange deck I don't
understand then he played night before
yeah did he play night before there yeah
but that was like in the middle game I
don't understand that
okay so Queen back to be 695 Queen to be
draw greed
I don't why that didn't happen yeah okay
so Queen b6 c3 yeah I've never been so
ashamed to look at White's position a 5x
clam Knight d3 so somehow white avoided
losing immediately shocking because
white gave up the two bishops white
didn't Castle white moved his Bishop
eighty five times that he gives other
Bishop away they moved his
about seven times Mischa basics looks
good that's what he played okay then h3
forced the knight to a good square
castles which I don't believe could
somebody explain castles to me you can't
explain it okay now Spencer says says
why not take this then what he plays H
takes Jia may sit on the a trial I mean
I don't believe that but okay yeah no I
mean like it's it's mathematically
possible but you know I don't believe
anything so there's no threats there's
pretty big threats you might check me
once yeah yeah it'll be okay for black
it'll be more okay for white yeah now
you shouldn't allow this agreed
especially when your opponent's gonna
cast left your knight f6 this is this
pawn attacked is there nothing to do
about it
maybe there's nothing do about it
because the B to pawn the d3 night
everything's attacked he played Age 3
making sure you could attack something
instead of just castle
so maybe but if white castles can black
secretly take this pawn here this is
Queen can you take this and win upon or
it's frankly ridiculous
no c3 is hanging right so you can so you
can do it so maybe here like White's
somehow in trouble because every move he
made no sense yeah black has the two
bishops and they're crisscrossing like
that great rap group from the 80s was it
80s or 90s 90s my covers like criss
cross now you're talking my talk yeah
who was worse criss cross or oh this is
being filmed or somebody not good
somebody who murdered many people put
millions of them all right so yeah his
game is just horrible
okay h3 night us castles is just
terrible you were shocked what did you
expect resigns Bishop III X clam that's
nothing to sneeze at Bishop III Knight
takes pawn which is a piece so that's
bad
mmm Queen b3 but after Queen b3 can he
play Knight c1 x clam I'm not even
kidding
if you might Castle next game yeah okay
so you expected Bishop III as opposed to
hanging the e pawn always a good idea
Queens see something we're gonna say
it's too even though it's not because
you know I know you're out seven but
we'll just say - Shh
don't tell anybody okay then you played
Knight c5 winning more material or not
really cuz ninety-seven what so not
really
alright and then takes Bishop f1 Knight
d7 then you have a great intermezzo
I just don't know what it is okay so
you'd play just take this Queen b5x clan
queen queen jumps over double jump Queen
c5 Rick fe1 saving his rook so you have
the center the two bishops and extra
pawn yeah pretty good Eve I've advancing
your Center and then Bishop e3 but you
saw it and then Knight g5 which I don't
get eight six
I missed a move how dare you claim I
missed a move well maybe maybe maybe
maybe you missed a move I didn't yeah
Queen C 494 is this still right okay d5
Queen h4 Bishop c5 then you went to win
his knights and he played Queen be 3x
clam that's gotta be the worst score on
the board for his queen so okay then you
played were kb1
possibly b8
Queen a3 Queen c6 possibly f6 right now
his knights well-placed to be captured
mmm okay so he's got this great defense
going here so rookie 3x clam with Ag of
rook f3 and winning f7 and black
resigned now we'll look at our next game
no I'm kidding
yeah it looks like you know you're not
yeah now why can't we do stuff here you
can't do anything can you play e4 x clan
then you can't play rook f3 is that bad
somebody explain f3 bishop f8 resigns
you agree with that analysis I refute it
f3 with bishop f8 it's when I point that
out yes I don't know how to point that
out but yeah for those of you at home
pay attention to my lectures you'll get
the jokes more well he wants to play
rook f3 right so II for that he can't
play rook f3 were you afraid of 94
Bishop e7 4 key which doesn't work right
I agree but I want to play Bishop f8 and
take his Knight that's what I want to do
and and if you play it he'll play rook
f3 so if you play E 4 then you won't
play rook f3 then I'll play [ __ ]
renovate and take is nice
I don't know if there's a defense to
that might come or what's the defense
also if I don't play Bishop hane take
your knight what do you do Fe for you
like in stalemate the game is a draw
yeah why his positions not good there's
good and there's not good it's not good
don't sue me the sopranos okay so well
why aren't you winging the way you
played you played rugby 7x clam and then
he played Knight to g4 efore ah fool me
7 or more time shame on me and you saw
that coming
yeah I know yeah so it looks like that
after the e4 that blacks better
because bishop fa and you take the night
I don't see a defense
what's the defense Spence okay but you
looked at e4 but you don't know what you
were worried about yet you do then but
now you don't know ah you thought they
both win with an e4 like ah yeah so one
thing I tell my students is whenever
you're playing chest and you're not
doing anything and it's your opponent's
move and you're like bored okay
Julian's like what do you mean it's
always my opponent's move anyway look
for pieces that are defended and not
defended so like the bishop on e6 is not
protected so it's all skier it's all
yella okay the other piece is on the
board except for the rook on d1
are also not protected and when you play
rook d7 you unprotect your rook which
seems like it's irrelevant but then I
was right for once
now it is relevant okay so now you have
to win the game again but you're still
winning so whatever you get to just to
play have more fun although you can take
a scorekeeping class because yeah I'm
good I'm getting tired of correcting
this Knight d4 okay so Queen f4 Knight
g3 Don the Knights really active Queen
c4 I don't understand oh you want to
play something to b3 okay yeah be 4x
clam yeah f5 Ricky e1 e 497 I assume e2
takes Bishop takes b4 X clam yeah is
there a referee you can throw in the
towel it's a good thing our jizz is down
here he's too young to see this yeah I
know
now I'm right you can't look at this
okay rook D to be seven that's legal
Bishop d6 didn't say that was legal now
can you play rook b3x clam or did I hang
everything and I probably trap you my
queen or something
so how confident were you a victory No
wow that's pretty confident
Rick c8 X clam Bishop c5 you know black
can't really do a why can't do all work
here Queen a something we're gonna say
too even though it says something else I
think it says the symbol for Batman okay
rook C to be a bishop b4 that looks
pretty risky don't you have some trick
that wins immediately rook takes Bishop
was immediately no no I'm not sacking
I'm just taking a free bishop you know
what I mean the look of disgust on his
face it's like he's watching a Cardinals
game doesn't that win a lot also is it
white like 1800 what's going on around
here what has he given that he's giving
it away
argent is this move good rook takes
Bishop what do you think but you didn't
see it here like I didn't see I was like
that looks terrible there's got to be a
win yeah what do you think Mike comer
rook takes Bishop with advantage yeah
you didn't want to fix his puns
okay so every move wins C fives even
meaner because then he's got to keep his
terrible Bishop Bishop a3 then you took
that oh how old are you you have to
leave because you can't see this this is
rated pg-13 over here you can okay yeah
that's why you didn't play rook takes b4
incase argent was looking yeah okay rook
anyone okay what was better than rook a1
the answer is funny
correct cuz I can't I'm not gonna play
rook a1 I refuse to have this position
with Wyatt okay you have no shame okay
did you think you'd win now yeah Bishop
takes e 2x clam then
trechie mark takes then bishop takes c6
BAM alright you're keeping it scouring
time trouble you don't do that then
you're gonna lose on time now the move
everybody overlooked yeah this should
take c5 and I'd hate to be God right now
cuz he sees everything maybe like no
Bishop takes e5 very suspicious right
you agree with that that's how you would
have done it
what rugby ones the worst know that or
queen takes why is that better than
queen tags
well you're right rook takes wins and
Queen takes is equal death
so did your opponent were you shake your
head of your opponent like why are you
playing so bad no that was the right
move okay so you played someone that
took all of his pieces Queen takes solid
I like his move it takes something this
this rook takes check King h2 I'm not
going to actually say what it says but
King h2 was the move d4 yeah I agree
with that move you don't like g4 I do
Rick b2 then white shaded all the rooks
because that was the best way to get
counter play King g1x clam yeah yeah I
know
bishop here King f1x clam and then Wow
then it's that some crazy stuff is
written here yeah and then you won yeah
so in the opening your opponent played
Bishop here here here here that you took
them but I think it's important you know
this kind of tactic where after Bishop
to b4 that you that you take it right
Nikki like rook takes Bishop and then
you're up a bishop
the other rook takes Oh taking on c3
yeah
and again if you remember earlier in the
lecture I said about pieces that weren't
defended and the Queen on H who's not
defended and one thing you want to think
about our x-rays okay like I had some
x-rays last week and I might not be
teaching here what next week if you know
what I mean does x-rays didn't look so
good but they don't get nothing I hope
you got it at home you know terrible
okay
you're terrible audience just a terrible
audience even the cameraman yeah look at
them you know smoke see professional
okay now this game was very similar
because there's only one name just like
in the last game so so you're mad and
you're playing are poor Evan Smith plus
tax yeah
okay this game went d4x clam and now
white made a mistake calm ski style and
I'd like to point out for those of you
at home my annotation my brilliant
annotations to the consu you were taken
off the web that true story yeah
censorship at the chess club so there
should have 4.com ski style yeah if you
saw my annotations you wouldn't play
that
okay so Knight f6 III Bishop f5 oh we
need some smelling salts for the
audience here pretty boring game so far
see 696 cops key would be happy now wait
a minute this says e six and his next
move is Bishop e6
oh it's Bishop e7 okay I got it this
should ease seven castles castles now it
says Bishop e5 okay so we're gonna go
back to the Bishop d6 theory here okay
then you played Knight e5 and everybody
castled except yeah black castles first
right and then you each took this and
he's my student now I give him one
lesson so that explains it okay yeah
don't do that that's a good Bishop now
he wanted to play a blunder Knight bd7
but only origin sees why that's a
blunder and Bensimon right and everybody
else
in fact there's more than one way for
whites to get an advantage does the
class like taking on c6 or f7 discuss
who says Knight takes c6 is correct
who says Knight takes f7 is correct you
like f7 Arjun Oh an extra night f7 rook
takes Bishop takes black gets a free
move in there so you're taking the
b-pawn instead of the F pawn interesting
you know they're both good teams they
both win so I don't know okay so you he
took aa horrible okay then you took with
the pawn which I wouldn't do that's
probably right yeah that's better taken
with the bishop I would take with the
bishop because I like my bishop so I
wouldn't do this because it blocks my
Bishop see you have a dark squared
bishop and he doesn't because I said so
and I'm right for once
you can't even argue at home you're
trying to argue at home you're like any
like okay so now your bishop is good
because it's good and he'll never win
your bishop cuz you're gonna save it
somehow bishop g3 h3 and then for the
next 70 moves your bishop will wreak
havoc right Arjun that good answer good
coaching okay you took with the pawn I
can't agree although I still prefer
white then he moved his knight I agree
with that though there was a trading
fest alright now you may have noticed
you have two bishops so that's usually
good although your Bishop on f4 is a
little iffy now cuz you blocked it so
you traded off one of your bishops for
his I'm not a big fan of that but he
refused showed you okay which I agree
with cuz you probably want to get more
Center pawns and then you moved your
queen and he developed his knight
finally and it says Bishop g6 c5 I don't
believe any of that Oh bishop g3 okay c5
yeah f4x Clem okay Queenie seven okay
now the last thing you want to do is
play Bishop takes Bishop you
punishes bishop send it to the room
without supper and you want to advance
your whatever this is called you know
space advantage why are you yellow
that's better
okay so you want to push those funds
like this in robot style for some reason
so if you could you would play e4 and f5
if you could cheat like two O's in a row
then he would resign even though he's
fine after c-4 so so first I would
probably stop c-4 with something like b3
and then play e4 f5 and then if the
pawns get traded your Bishop on g3
improves because this pawns not here so
you can you have a nice diagonal and you
don't have doubled pawns anymore see if
I make another color this one yeah those
are my three colors so I don't really
like taking this because then this
Bishop I don't know about that Bishop
yeah now I heard you guys discussing
there while I was having some Thai food
which way to take on g6 now we have a
master in the audience and he will
explain the right move
they just say F takes was played I think
that thinks is good okay I think blacks
better either way yeah because well
because F takes that seems nice like
white will never play f5 or anything
also after age takes I'll play Queen g4
row page three and mate you like I might
but after up takes I can't do anything
yeah can I turn an engine and prove
myself wrong but I don't know how to do
anything well let's see when I push one
of these now I help control 3 yeah it
says F shakes is better than whites
better so the machines the engines wrong
in both cases that that was like the
worst that ever happened in my life now
you ruined your thing okay
control - you're serious
no wow you're the smartest guy in your
chair don't touch his chair Arjun okay
so f takes is recommended by the
computer it says whites better which
doesn't make any sense okay
but f takes is good then efore I agree
we got to get those pawns going that b3
stopping the night that's good you want
to control your opponent's pieces good
he wanted to take with the night after a
AED lesson was about Rick a g8x clam
Rick a d1 d4 I don't know about that
Queen B 5 wow I wouldn't play that
because I don't understand it I'm trying
to push on the King side over here ok so
he played Queen c7 and you pushed on the
Queen side and he attacked your Queen
and you saw it Queen c6 I like I like
moving that night to 8 8 didn't see that
coming
I liked ITA you go to c7 b5 c3 but I
like that
well I wouldn't keep it on a it now this
reminds me of the famous game Feingold 9
1986 where a non blitzed out the move
Knight AJ and I was like what like and I
didn't attack his Knight he's played 9h8
I was like huh and he wanted to play
Knight f7 Knight g5 9 f3 winning but I
drew anyway because we were as a solid
game anyway I like Knight a8 because you
get to reconnoitre over here although I
heard he didn't so Queen c4 and then
some scribbling and that's it there's no
more moves so this game continued and
you were in time trouble and then you
had seconds and he had seconds and you
lost on time and when you launched on
time what was the verdict you got you
had him at hello but then it was goodbye
yeah yeah don't sue me the Beatles
well you have a lot of mousse were made
that it changed the whole dynamic of the
position yeah okay so that game was
actually pretty good there was no big
mistakes but then in time trouble there
were big mistakes I heard and what was
the final position you grew up a lot of
material part of the seventh which one
the point on e5 now and then you knew
you're gonna win but your flag fell yeah
yeah when I play usually there's some
increment or delay but when I was
younger which was always I was always
younger than I am now we didn't have
delay and increment all that so we just
lost on time that's how we rolled now
here's a masterpiece of scorekeeping
it's not even mine although according to
Preston it is mine because it's my flesh
and blood so we're the same according to
Preston that's how that works
this is the famous game Justin GM Hall
vs. NM spencer feingold and for those of
you at home
GM is his name not his title okay his
title is ng M not a GM and they played
the Brier system unless you don't call
it that would you call it the Brier no
okay you tried to play the Brier but now
the Breyers a good opening when it's hot
outside cuz no ice cream is good when
it's hot Bishop a4 9f well you played me
I have sex okay and this is the real
Lopez or as they call it in Europe
Spanish right this should be for our
European viewers this should be seven
that's why I was gonna cafe au lait okay
rook e1 b5 this should be three and this
is so many real dope has to start like
this now normally they play C three but
your opponent played Age 3 you weren't
interested in playing the Marshall game
but you didn't Castle okay so you so so
Age 3 Chomsky style yeah castles
yeah after after c3 the bishop can go to
see - oh because I said so
right and after not playing c3 you can't
go to see - so if we go back a move in
this position if black decides I want to
win that Bishop Knight a5 9 takes Bishop
what's wrong with that anyone anyone
yeah what's wrong with Knight a5 winning
the bishop - easy for you to - crazy for
crazy town
yes yeah you're EEP ones not defended so
much
so after d6 your pawn is defended so
much so now in 1985 would get the two
bishops so white normally plays c3 not
only preparing d4 but saving the bishop
castles okay and h3 you castled c3 and
you played the the Brier with Knight be
it and that's a regular Brier
okay so now everybody plays d4 now for
those of you audience who are confused
which is all of you except Spencer who
played it and he's still a little
confused 98 was invented by Breyer in
the 1880s sovereign needs 70s maybe okay
don't don't email and write me I don't
read your emails I don't know when they
invented it and the idea is to play
Knight bt7 and Bishop b7 your bishops
good on b7 it's being cut out your
Knight goes to c5 and if white plays d4
d5 and blocks up your bishop you can
play C 6 and many super grand masters
including Carlsen and calm ski play the
Brier a lot and when I prepared for Josh
Friedel in the norm tournament had just
finished he plays the Brier also in fact
freed all was white in the Brier against
calm ski ones they both play the Brier
so Spencer plays the Breyer all the time
what do you
yeah so normally it's like d4 Knight
here probably night here but I'm wrong I
don't know
this should be seven and millions of
super GM games so you played Bishop e7 x
clam well this didn't happen he played a
4x clam
I don't either okay so a four you saw
the threat good player it should be
seven yeah
okay then d3 that's the way they're
playing it now boring is possible now in
my professional opinion as a super
Grandmaster I mean like I'm a
grandmaster I'm a super guy not a super
Grandmaster this should be three very
suspicious I don't think the bishop
belongs on e3 because then I can't yeah
and then this is gonna happen and you
know why is the bishop on you three so
normally they move the knight around a
lot fiddler style which replaced Gangnam
style Knight d2 night here night here
and then the other night goes Dage to
Queen f3 and you would have lost for
sure
okay so Bishop III sort of loses a tempo
cuz we can't play Knight d2 because it's
not our turn
c5 X clam then Bishop seats who I don't
understand
oh you're gonna play c4 win the e4 pawn
maybe well okay then he played Knight
bTW too but it's nice when they play
Bishop c2 you didn't make them like you
played Bishop b3 then Bishop c2 you
didn't like play Knight a5 so okay so
this is about as boring as it comes you
know so it's sort of like the boring
world of niels bohr but it's a little
more exciting than that soon because you
act on your opponent to okay now even
the most dim-witted individual with an
advanced being hyperbolic topology will
tell you Knight g3 is the right move
right then yeah but your opponent played
takes AA giving up his e pawn on the
other hand this Bishop is pretty good on
the diagonal in fact that diagonal
should be a different color it's so good
about that color yeah there we go
that means the bishops ready to go so so
he took which I don't agree with what
about you
yeah cuz the night is good on d5 ok then
9 g3 and then you add the two bishops
and he took back which is pretty good
and you played rook Fe 8 and rook ACA
you were proud of rook a CA because you
thought it stopped d4 and then you take
on d4 and as Bishop on c2 is hanging
because d4 would open up this bishop on
the diagonal but if d4 can't be played
then it won't open the bishop up in the
diagonal taking the e pawn allows Bishop
g5 exclam attacking all of White's
pieces a brilliant tactical coup which
is correct right ok so there was an
under move you were thinking of playing
but he could take it there was some
trick a bishop of ad for it as bishop
comes alive the night goes to f5 yeah so
Rick AC 8 X clam and now Knight f5 makes
sense
Bishop f8 makes sense Knight fh 4 who
taught you how to keep score I assume
this one okay then you played Knight f6
he played rook g3 and he's ready to
attack you except he went a little crazy
King h8 and this position was probably
equal in theory I mean in practice but
in theory it said black was a little
better computer says blacks a little
better because whites attacking but some
of whites pieces are are not attacking
and black has that Ananda bishop which I
call it because of his game with Aronian
also his gave a top along where he also
he wasn't world championship mean when
the World Championship against Topalov
and against Aronian he won the greatest
game ever hmm it's a top of our vision
okay so that mission about b7 is pretty
good Bishop on F fate is always my
favorite defending everything pawn on e5
is annoying it's in the center I always
like when a work and a queen are on the
same file because then the rook crushes
the Queen so black has a lot of
advantage
and Weis playing for me okay so now the
computer wants you to play Queen d7 okay
Queen III was played and he wants to
play Queen d7 you played efore starting
off a firework of tactics and since we
all know the Kate Perry is not very good
fireworks didn't work yeah or you like
Kate Perry no no nothing never heard of
Kate Perry
all right so ninth g7x clam you knew he
would do it okay and then he sacked
everything that you took everything and
then he checked you so if you play King
age 7 or King h8 or King f8 then you'll
probably lose to Queen age 6 and main so
you decided not to lose now if Queen age
6 King takes tonight you're a lot of
pieces up if you have a very well stack
database I remind you of the game the
only person will who knows this game
including the players Berliner post
shall I'm gonna say 1963 and in that
game was a Sicilian post shot walked his
king up the board taking pieces then he
walked his King back and Berliner
resigned he's like man I got no pieces
but Poe shells King was on d5 on move 14
and then he walked it back to he ate he
was like all right you win but he took
pieces with his king all the way up
there so yeah after Queen h6 ping out 5
very similar
then you drop a lot of pieces and walk
your King back so Queen h6 doesn't work
so he gave you the check he showed you
he said two pieces they checked you so
he played Shak and now you went to crazy
town by repeating okay instead of not
repeating what's that Wow okay yeah I
agree
King aged seven and he played nine f5
and you always repeat possibly not the
best and then you played Knight g8x clam
and you defended so that was the end of
his ideas yeah so when you stack all
your pieces and you don't see a force
mate don't stack all your pieces
because you you won't have any pieces so
he sack all his pieces he checked you a
couple of times he said okay I give up
so I was playing a game once with Nick
de fer me and he have a database at home
us championship 1999 Salt Lake City and
I was given the business he 5 d5 and I
was winning and then he did something
where he's trying to check me and then
one of the grandmasters in the turn when
I showed him the game said I he plays
for check and he did check me I think
and then he resigned so here you're
pulling a place for check will he do it
for it all the checks exhausted de and
he wants to play e5 and check you so you
play Queen e5 and he can't check you now
let's see our intelligent audience here
how sharp they are if white plays the
obvious ff4 other than Spencer what will
black do no laughing Ben Simon he's like
you can't call him you I'm the cameraman
yeah he's like I'm not you know I'm not
on the clock here and you want you sir
yeah Queen takes tonight Ben Simon
recommended and we can't take the Queen
although we have to and then check haha
he checked you and it's almost made if
you didn't have for legal moves and
they're like four they only see like two
and they're confused those are for I
counted four really fast I could be
wrong
yeah you see four Wow okay anybody I'll
see four just honest you know there's
this good move this one okay all right
so f4 was not played instead he prepared
f4 so eventually he'll check you
although he's done a rook so when you
sacrifice all your pieces you shouldn't
like hope to check your opponent you
should have like the stuff figured out
so he played nine g3x clam Spencer
played c4 and Spencer was ready for f4
that's why he played c4 and f4 was
played Queen c5 and now that the Queen's
are off the board his extra work will
tell and now i blundered horribly he
could have played 'if i check
and he resigned instead so he actually
could have gotten his check in then
after King h8 he's down a rook and the
Queen's would be traded but he could
have got a check in and he has two pawns
for a rock I I believe you can disagree
Preston would not resign with Wyatt the
end say he was better
well maybe not Knight f5 to d6 and
winning yeah okay so those were pretty
good games except for the last three you
know who got that oh okay and good good
score q except for the mistake you made
night after age four
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]